Okay, let's fill out this concept map and see
how you did. Let's start with the personal DNA sample,
which can be used for genome sampling and comparison.
We learned how to acquire this personal DNA sample in
lesson seven, and what we're going to be doing is
genome sampling and comparing individual SNVs. Now an IBS score
or Identity By State is a score based on
individual comparisons of individual SNVs. This indicates a genetic identity
which we have greater than 70% of for
all SNV matches in humans. Remember that you
share at least 70% IBS with even the
most distantly related human on the planet. This
is a rough approximation. Now another kind of
scoring involves the IBD, or identity by descent,
which scores based on segments of chromosomes sharing
individual SNVs. And this indicates genetic relatedness, which can
reduce to about 1% for third cousins and
beyond. Now altogether, the SNVs that we measure are
located on the Y chromosome, which can be
used to trace the paternal lineage. The mitochondrial chromosome,
which is used to trace the maternal line.
And autosomes and the X chromosome, which altogether, can
be used to trace close and distant family
relations. Putting all of this information together, we've learned
that it indicates a human origin out of
Africa. With each expansion experiencing genetic bottlenecks, specifically
referred to as a founder effect. But we
learned about these bottle necks more in lesson six.